kein windrad bauen und dafür andere
energieformen welche zum beispiel atom
und die gefahren die durch atomkraft
ausgeht stichwort fukushima ich weiß
nicht wo der reflexe meyer kommt dass
der neue atom oder reaktor hören dass er
sofort ablehnen und herrscht tschernobyl
ist ein schlechtes beispiel
[Musik]
wieso hast du jetzt auch eine latzhose
an dabei ist heute doch um natur geht
hat die redaktion noch so entschieden
viel natur das ist mein privater
kleidungsstil wieso überhaupt redaktion
hallo kann man kaum richtig richtig ich
trage die latzhose doch nur weil du doch
mal ein großes vorbild bist okay jetzt
macht natürlich alles total sinn und
mein zweites vorbild neben dir natürlich
ist übrigens ein tier der wolf wir
beißen uns beide gerne fest und essen
beide gerne lang haha ich weiß jetzt
nicht ob ich dich mit einem wolf
vergleichen will nur heute kennen döner
ist aber lamm ist lang und wenn dir
erstmal ein wolf aus der hand gefressen
hat dann weisst du was ich meine
in deutschland gibt es seit jahren nur
ein thema es geht um einwanderung
integration und obergrenzen sie wissen
wovon ich rede
der wolf dazu schaue ich nicht nur im
bundestag vorbei sondern treffe auch
wolfs befürworter gegner und betroffene
sollte endlich mal ein wichtiges thema
der wolf erfreulich für gerade
debattiert ja kriegen sie das nicht wird
das verdanke die jetzt gerade ins kino
es geht zum thema wölfe auch haben sie
da keine zeit für wollen sie den wolf
jagen weil sie frau merkel nicht kriegen
dem wollte ich leidenschaftslos muss ich
sagen also ich bin also fisch vegetarier
sind erste kleinere doch zum glück gibt
es auch noch politiker mit echten
lösungsansätzen
ob der wolf wirklich das große problem
ist weil wir haben lösungen jenseits des
abschusses ja zum beispiel könnte man
ihn auch als diesel tester bei vw
einsetzen ich glaube vor wie muss kein
diesel mehr testen die wissen schon ganz
genau was der diesel angerichtet weil
sie das problem sind die jungen und
begleiteten wölfe vor genau das wissen
sie genau was mir die erstmal groß
werden und dann schauen wir mal
wenn man nach rotkäppchen geht wäre der
wolf wir auch ein gutes rezept gegen
altersarmut zb hier könnte man auch
sagen ach die wirklich muss man zum
abschuss freigeben
wichtig ist habe ich gab es ganz anderes
gehört ja dann muss der kollege noch
dazulernen und dann wurde es nochmal
richtig emotional
warum wollen sie die wölfe abschließen
wir haben ganz viele risse und alles ja
natürlich klar es gibt gutachter und
anderes mehr
die grünen sagen dann immer man muss man
muss sich darum kümmern dass man die
tierische und wer soll das bezahlen es
kann doch nicht sein dass wir von den
indern und in afrikanern verlangen dass
die löwen und tiger schützen
wir wollen diese nicht ausrotten bevor
sie sich prügeln ich bin neutral wollte
ich nur kurzzeitig weiter freuen sie
sich doch mal dass endlich meine art
nach deutschland wieder einwandert dass
wir unsere fauna bereichert wird dadurch
aber über einwanderung und anderes
listen tätig ist nämlich gut leben das
ist um einwanderung geht ja jamaika in
den appell jetzt geht's nach brandenburg
wo mehr wölfe leben als spd-wähler
obwohl das gilt inzwischen auch für nrw
sie sind also gegen den wolf wir müssen
gegen den wolf sein der wolf frisst
unsere kelber der frist unsere schafe
und jeder der eine vernünftige
ökologische landwirtschaft betreibt der
will natürlich tiere auf der weide
halten und der wolf macht es unmöglich
aber haben sie schon mal am gegessen
natürlich habe ich mal haben vor dem
wolf werfen sie es vor
mythos wollen dass alles verschlingende
monster rassen gutes gefühl
oder doch eher laktose-intoleranz männer
sie fressen tatsächlich auch walnüsse
waldbeeren also im prinzip alles kann
man guter salat auch dabei sein
nach außen wieder salat dabei seien
genau
wenn sie dem wolf vegane lebensweise
beibringen ja dann kommen wir ins
geschäft ja aber wir als menschen wollen
natürlich essen und wir wollen das
fleisch auf eine naturnahe weise
produzieren und dafür brauchen wir
kinder wenn der wolf veganer wäre wenn
idiot ja und deshalb bin ich auch kein
veganer so einfach ist das die würfel
gesehen
die herde war unruhig ist waren
hinterher gefahren und hat den wolf
gesehen hatten aber nicht bekommen
sie haben eine richtige verfolgungsjagd
aufgenommen und ich wollte meine herde
beschützen und schießen darf man sich
was soll man sonst mal ne überfahren
schon beeindruckende tiere muss ich
sagen
die schöne tieren ja
[Musik]
wer zum geprügelt wenn zuvor baute
worden was für ein emotionaler tag in
wut und habe ich auch gesagt
stellen sie sich vor ich wäre jetzt der
wolf und dann können sie mir einfach mal
persönlich sagen was sie fühlen
ich finde sie sind toller typ aber hab
ja ich will hier nicht sehen
natürlich bei den anderen parteien auch
immer von daher passt doch ein ganz
normaler dreh und damit zurück ins
studio schon toll wenn du bist du bist
viel an der frischen luft verarbeitet
gesunde und regionale produkte über
fährst mit einem alten euro fiel diese
wölfe aber ich weiß dass du meinst ich
habe da auch schon darüber nachgedacht
zu zweites standbein und so war klar
gerade in deinem alter stichworte
altersarmut
weißt du was ich zeig dir jetzt mal wie
ich bauer werde und wenn ich sauer bin
mit ganz viel kühl und so dann schenke
ich dir literweise frische milch warum
damit du groß und stark wirst mal wieder
punkt für von da ab dem bums
hallo ich wollte mich ich will selbst
bauer werden
haben sie irgendwelche tipps für mich
was muss ich da machen ich glaube als
bauer brauchen sie erst mal eine
berufsausbildung das ist nämlich nicht
was man so ebenso mal macht wie im
garten sondern da braucht man eine
ordentliche berufsausbildung ehrlichen
beruf also anders als ihr beide sondern
sagen ja politik muss man wirklich was
können ja das ist selbstkritisch dass
wir nicht gut ja welche richtung wollen
sie den landwirt egal hauptsache weg vom
fernsehen egal da müssen sie auf öko
machen dann haben sie die meiste arbeit
und dem höchsten verdienst
wieso das denn
wie komme ich dann das geld welches geld
ich will ja selber auch geflügel bauer
werden könnten sie mir jetzt mal zeigen
wie man also ein küken professionell
schreddert wir schreiten solche küken
nicht
ich dachte die werden heutzutage werden
die menschen nicht geschrieben bekommen
die es lange nimmt so hatten die
zuschauer kennen die antwort kommen sie
auch nicht mehr stellt sich einmal vor
was sie so machen
mein name ist svenja schulze
bundesumweltministerin schulze wie
schulz schulz sowie schulz durch kein
gutes oben erstmal doch klar heißen
viele ist ein beliebter name ich will
selbst bauer werden
haben sie eine idee wie ich das nach
aktuellem wissensstand mache um
möglichst viele fördergelder abzugreifen
muss der betrieb möglichst groß und
möglichst asozial sollen
na ja im moment gibt es die fördergelder
der eu vor allen dingen wenn man viel
fläche hat also es wäre ganz gut werden
sie viele flächen haben auf dem sie in
der landwirtschaft betreiben und dass
das genau das was ich falsch finde
ja
[Applaus]
was ist das denn jetzt hier das ist eine
wirkung auf kurse gerät für diese
floralen konzentration da wären die
vergabe kastriert werden
wie das gemacht wird ja gerne gerne das
werksteam von der wucht so weg kriegt
ihr fahrrad so rein macht so zu dann
geht so fest ja und da hoffen lassen zum
fixieren
das ist schön sind sie schön so weg dass
man schon in großstädten kam wie hier
auf dem film sehen dann kommt die grüne
lampe zu hören nicht nur nicht jetzt
sie hat nichts passiert nicht drücken
sie sich den grünen knopf hinterher
verhinderung da haben wir sind der
erfinder von der förder kastrations-
maschine werde sich jetzt eher gedacht
das ist eine frau empfindet so eine
kastration es ist eine fantastische
karriere von der weinkönigin zu schwein
königin
das mögen sie sachlich
ich bin auch in schweinemist ich hab
auch abitur ein führerschein baku also
ich muss ich noch mal ein kompliment
machen sie haben gezeigt was für einem
freien land wir leben in einem land in
dem man schweine ohne betäubung
kastrieren kann zwei jahre lang noch
fantastisch das wird sich ändern und ich
sage ihnen dadurch dass ich jetzt etwas
auf den weg gebracht hat was verändert
gehabt dass wir jetzt die isofluran
verordnung da geht es um eine
vollnarkose und wir werden am ende
dieser zwei jahre weiter sein als alle
anderen europäischen länder
ok erzählen sie es nicht mehr erzählen
sie den ferkeln das sind die armen
schweine noch mal es geht darum dass wir
zum beispiel auch bei meinem tier wohl
kennzeichen das sich entwickelt da wird
eine betäubungslose ferkelkastration
nicht möglich sein das heißt wenn sie
fleisch kaufen mit einem tier wohl
kennzeichen dann ist das fleisch von
nicht betäubungslos kastrierten
schweinen also ist dann nicht von den
ist das tut man zealand herald land mehr
als schöne frau interessieren sich nicht
für mich ist auch schlecht müssen wir
schauen wie sie anderen besitzt kommen
also ein highlight man sie zum beispiel
heirate ich eine reiche bäuerinnen wäre
eine idee haben sie kontaktdaten wenn
ich dir hätte ihn dort nicht
[Musik]
eigentlich eine schöne nummer aber
irgendwas war doch komisch ich weiß was
du meinst total unrealistisch dass stoff
ferkel nicht kastriert worden ist das
glaubt ihm keiner und war das eigentlich
die echte julia klöckner
ja klar warum weil da gar kein
großkonzern als sponsor dabei war das
recht ich rufe sofort olli an
wir sind reingelegt worden titanic
postillion alles ist möglich
dann hole ich mir was zu trinken alles
klar bis gleich pass auf manchmal
überkommt nicht plötzlich ein
unfassbarer durst nach grundwasser an
aber kann man es noch bedenkenlos
trinken
[Musik]
wenn sie die neue düngeverordnung
geschissen finde ich die donnerstags für
dünger ist das die antwort auf frage ist
for future was ist breit ist ob youtube
massentierhaltung und nitrat da gibt es
keinen ursächlichen zusammenhang aber
massentierhaltung produziert ja
dementsprechend auch mehr gülle die muss
irgendwohin
das ist unbedingt unser grundwasser ist
nicht verseucht ich komme also aus
friesland
das ist nicht versorgt der boden nimmt
das auf wir haben auch einen anderen
ersten unterboden das auf und wir haben
optimal da geben dann geht das nicht
weiter nein nein
und warum zeigen dann die messwerte das
nitrat und was die da bin ich das
erfordert müssen uns gemeinsam gehen und
wir müssen alle zusammen rücken das ist
nicht nur bauern mit julia sondern es
müssen wieder auch verbraucher müssten
zusammen wie ich gehen weil sonst kommen
lebenswelt nicht mehr aus deutschland
weiß nie was jemand möchte von euch da
wir wollen ja vor allem keinen keine
scheiße im wasser
kollege war keine gefahr ist folgen
ja ich weiß auch von mir verwandtschaft
irgendwo wer weiß vielleicht sehe ich so
wenn es mal winken bei so sind die
eckelsheimer ich weiß gar nicht ob nicht
irgendwo dahinten ja genau jetzt
wahlweise sind wie war das klima so
eigenen cd gramm nitrat das ist doch in
ordnung dass für sie ist es gut für mich
ist es aber kann ein ganz deutschland
aus ihrem brunnen trinken nein gibt es
nicht her
merken sie selbst nicht von der pflanze
erwarten also sagen sie ruhig ich bin
die pflanze stellt sich vor ich bin die
pflanze ja dann seid ihr jetzt dass du
jetzt mit dem ruhig du du musst mit dem
dünger clark um den den db geben können
maximum aber muss dafür dafür sollen wir
weizen in der qualität produzieren dass
man ein brot heraus machen kannst kombi
mit klar könnten können sie jetzt
einfach als pflanze sagen aber ob man ja
auch ja aber man kann es in der praxis
her wir können pflanzen lügen ja nicht
an pflanzen kann ja nicht reden
gutes gegenargument
[Musik]
wir bauen sind langsam nur noch gefühlt
der buhmann der nation
und das kann ja auch nicht sein dass die
gülle dass sich die unternehmen die die
die gülle durch die gegend kutschieren
sich 100 kilometer sieht man ja
tagtäglich dass die sich dann eine
goldene nase mit verdienen wird die
gülle for gold recht richtig
sda
wo wir heute gar nicht drüber geredet
haben was ist denn mit diesen ganzen
abwässern aus diesen ganzen
kanalisationen aus den großstädten oder
wann sind die denn alle noch dicht hat
keiner drüber geredet also jetzt sind
wieder die großstädter gleich voll
scheiße zu glauben dass nitrat nur wegen
der bauern ins wasser kommt ist falsch
vor 500 jahren waren
naturwissenschaftliche zusammenhänge die
man nicht verstehen konnte immer ganz
einfach zu erklären man hatte die hexe
und die wut frau brandi war schuld heute
ist es wenn das geschenk langsam angst
sie mich gleich betäubungslose
kastrieren leide ich kein problem ich
habe darüber womit ich kann das
routiniert aber ich mache das nicht bei
erwachsenen
[Musik]
ich habe viele nette bauern kennen
gelernt und zum glück nimmt mich einer
mit nach köln und damit zurück ins
studio zu sein diese ich habe ja noch so
eine moderation vermisst wie besorgte
bauern ballern giftige gülle in gesundes
grundwasser genial getextet was ist das
da ich für eine kiste neben dir das ist
mein geheimnis ich lasse mich ja nicht
mehr in euro bezahlen
in diesen zeiten muss man auch etwas
sicheres setzen gold bitcoin spargel
das war echt eine schlimme zeit als wir
wegen corona zu wenig erntehelfer hatten
und auf ungelernte unbegleitete männer
zurückgreifen mussten du meinst ich
meine dich
deutschland in der spargel krise das ist
meine chance systemrelevant zu sein und
außerdem bin ich gerade ziemlich pleite
und braucht dringend kohle und so schwer
wird sehr wohl ich sei
[Musik]
hallo ich bin der lutz ja schön ich bin
herr kister ja herr kessler ist es freut
mich ich will helfen ich will auch
spargel stechen und ich sag mal kann er
nicht so das große problem sein oder
die leute stellen sich ein bisschen an
man wolle mit der gießkanne hier dachte
dass mal ein bisschen gießt vor dem
stechen dann kommen sie her aus köln
habe mir gedacht ja wie stellen sich vor
also ich gehe jetzt erstmal da ganz
vorurteilsfrei ran also ich hab mich
jetzt auch nicht groß vorbereitet merken
sie sich einen satz der spargelstecher
anstich spargel mit dem spargel
stechmesser und legt den gestochenen
spargel in die spargelstecher kiste der
spargelstecher stich den spargel stechen
weiß oder grün lassen
im wasser ziehen
sogar der grossbank hat eine große
nummer
ach ist doch was vom sparen
frage ist das hier nur weißt du wieder
aussieht ja ja magst du sprache vor
allem die köpfchen ich mag am liebsten
über die köpfe in den rest schmeiße ich
weg was zu viel geld also vor carola
hatte ich hatte ich doch zu viel geld
also jetzt er sich auch den ganzen sport
so wo ist hier in diesem gebiet wo steht
die frage ja gar nicht mehr so einfach
direkt erstmal zu machender vor augen
der spargel der hebt in einer gewissen
form den boden an und das geübte auge
sieht hat ich behaupte ich sehe ich
spare der fünf zentimeter unter der erde
unsere normalen polnischen und
rumänischen mitarbeiter die können hat
auch das über der erde stecken wie du
dann früh in meiner karriere dass ich
schaue mir schon ein habe ich auch noch
nicht gemacht ja aber warum ist das denn
so dass deutsche kein spargel stechen
könnten nutzer das ist sowie dem mit dem
können ich habe so eine sache wir
glauben wir können das nicht
wir kommen auf wohlstands region wohnt
eigentlich nicht mehr angebracht ist in
der nahrungsmittelproduktion zu arbeiten
gab es schon deutsche die jetzt hier
hingekommen sind und haben es probiert
das machen ja und die meist die noch da
die meisten sind nach zwei tagen
gescheitert 123 ja ja und jetzt hat
messer an den spargel heran für jahr an
zwei fingern oder ein fingerbreit so
naja und roswitha ich dich doch wenn der
duh hebel ja ist ja das gleiche
widerfahren
lieberman ändert die glöckner serie
klöckner bleibt aber nicht gestochen
jetzt meinen hass auf alles was macht
man denn jetzt in dem fall hochsprache
der kommen auch in die kiste wenn wir
das bruch ging verkauf der muss man das
köpfchen muss man ja nicht scheitern bin
ich halt ein spezialist für bruch sparen
würde ja da bin ich aber dann gehe ich
mit corona pleite oder mit der pleite
[Musik]
wie war das für dich so mal richtig zu
arbeiten haben ja auch ich habe immer
auch muskelkater
er fällt mir die perfekte überleitung
zum nächsten film ein
was steht wieder auf dem feld und dreht
sich nur um sich selbst ein windrad und
jetzt müssen wir nur noch in
windkraftgegner stimmung kommen
windräder die hat auch bill gates
erfunden um unsere finger zu schippen
genau
wir gehen jetzt nach hause und ihr denkt
da mal nicht drüber nach jawohl ich
wollte eigentlich nach tschernobyl aber
das war mir zu luftig stattdessen stehe
ich heute auge in auge mit einer der
gefährlichsten erfindungen die die
menschheit je gemacht hat
nein ich rede nicht von e scootern ich
rede von windrädern thüringer land cdu
windkraft forum gekommen sind vor allem
klimaleugner und windkraft gegner also
ein abend voller möglichkeiten
wir müssen ja wenn wir in deutschland
auf 100 prozent erneuerbare energien
kommen dann haben wir die solar- und
windenergie es ist doch vorgegeben
worden dass man das so machen will
es gibt eine ganze reihe anderer
möglichkeiten klären sie mich auf ich
wäre sie nie ich sage nur es gibt eine
ganze reihe von möglichkeiten wie man
mit dem mann als sie das arbeiten kann
also es gibt eine reihe von
möglichkeiten die wollen sie jetzt aber
nicht nennen
saison da sollte sich die politik mal
ein beispiel es gibt eine reihe von
möglichkeiten ja die nennen wir jetzt
aber nicht
aber es gibt eine reihe es gibt einige
möglichkeiten das noch anders zu können
natürlich kein windrad bauen und dafür
andere energieformen welche zb natur
die gefahren die durch atomkraft ausgeht
stichwort fukushima ich weiß nicht wo
der reflexe meyer kommt dass der neue
atom oder reaktor hören dass er sofort
ablehnen und herrscht ternopil ist sehr
schlechtes beispiel haben sollten der
expertin den klimawandel und es hagelt
natürlich kritik ach nee applaus sie
haben gerade auf der bühne den
menschengemachten klimawandel ignoriert
der menschgemachte klima mit es
höchstwahrscheinlich da steht nicht der
erste wiesn 99,7 prozent aller
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus aller
klimawissenschaftler wird er wird das
wird das status welt wird dato schwarz
bewiesen wie viele wissenschaftler davon
ausgehen glauben sie an den
menschengemachten klimawandel
ich glaube daran dass ist der mensch
eine aufgabe hat die klimaziele
einzuhalten und dafür müssen unseren
beitrag leisten sie an den
menschengemachten klimawandel
ich glaube daran dass die leute die
sorgen heim vor dem klimapolitischen
wirkung dass die nicht unberechtigt
sinne dass die politik verpflichtet ist
was zu machen wird die politik nicht
aber dafür angekreidet dass sie auf
einfache fragen die ich einfach
antwortet ohne diskussionen lebt von dem
spektrum worten wieder wort in
meinungsaustausch auch mit dem publikum
aber wenn sie zu einer podiumsdiskussion
mit experten geben dann sind sie als
bürger erstmal nicht so informiert wie
die experten da meisten die experten ja
auch experten darum lässt man sich ja
dann auch von den experten beeinflussen
deswegen wäre nicht gut wenn die
experten auch experten werden und ich
leute die meinungen haben und nicht auf
fakten basierende argumentieren
das ist wie beim zdf gibt experten die
ihre eigene meinung sagte und die nicht
immer die meinung der fernsehzuschauer
ist und trotzdem senden sie diese
anderen kommentar ein kritikpunkt an
windrädern ist ja dass zum beispiel der
rotmilan und auch andere vögel an den
windrädern zerschreddern welche alle
vögel insekten über der alles top und
das gar nicht nachvollziehen 100.000 im
jahr aber nur zum vergleich es sterben
18 millionen vögel jährlich an
glasscheiben in deutschland also es ist
ja so wie es ja so wie wenn sie mehrere
affären hätten und ihre frau verlässt
sie dann weil sie mal porno co
man kann das jetzt als vergleich setzen
es geht ja nicht bloß um alles ging mit
klimaleugner und windkraft gegnern hilft
nur eins upforce windrad ohren zu und
den infraschall genießen
herrlich weißt du worauf ich richtig
bock hab einen country songs schreiben
weißt du worauf ich hier richtig locker
bevor wir zwei ein countrysong schreiben
ein abo beim heute show you tube kanal
lassen und ein like und wenn ich schon
mal dabei bin schaue ich mir gleich die
aktuelle best of folge in der zdf
mediathek an geil ich hol schon mal mein
handy und ich einen stift und das bungee